[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Карпати,
село Либохора]
♪ Агов, подай голос. ♪
♪ Агов, подай голос, ♪
♪ Вівчарю молодикий, ♪
[Василина Ігнатиш,
скрипалька]
♪ ліщино зеленийка. ♪
♪ Агов, подай голос! ♪
♪ Агов, подай голос, ♪
♪ дівчино молодика! ♪
І вважалось,
що якщо дівчина відповість
на то «в'юкання»,
якщо хлопець...
— Значить той хлопець діло говорить.
— Так. Значить вона...
— Значить, той каже, що симпатія зароджується.
— Так, так. Зароджується симпатія.
А тепер як на мобільний написала смску,
значить є симпатія.
А тоді — в'юкання.
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
♪ Ой, люблю я вівчарити, з вівцями ходити ♪
♪ З високої полонини на село дивитись. ♪
♪ Пішли вівці в полонину самі половії, ♪
♪ а за ними вівчарики, хлопці молодії. ♪
[Леся Ігнатиш,
скрипалька]
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
До нашого фольклорно-етнографічного
колективу «Бескет»
входять:
ми, дві скрипальки,
цимбали, басоля,
бубон, дримба.
— Ті стародавні бойки...
— Сопілка, щe сопілка.
Дідусь був музикант,
потім наш батько, ми.
І вже мої діти.
Вони володіють цимбалами,
басолою, бубном.
Коли важко знайти учасників...
— Так.
— У фолькльорний колектив,
тому, що я кажу:
молодь не цікавиться тим.
Їх поглотили інші тенденції,
— ... інші новації, так.
— Важко знайти,
хто міг би володіти якимось
музикальним інструментом.
А сама назва «бойки»...
Хтось каже, що вони були
люди такі бойові, войовничі,
значить — «бойки».
А от інша версія є,
що «бо є».
Ну в нас, бойків,
кажуть там: «бо, бо».
Ми часто вживаємо
частку «бо»:
«бо так», «бо є».
«Як би було, бо так»
Напевно, може,
від цього навіть «бойки».
В принципі бойківщина була тому,
що Дрогобицька область колишня —
це Нижньоусіцький район,
зараз це — територія Польщі.
Але там повільніша музика.
Ось у нас тут в горах, суто в нас в горах,
у нас швидше музика.
— То там повільніше.
— Коломийки в нас такі запальні, а там...
А там вони такі повільніші, так.
♪ Ой віночку, мій зелений ♪
♪ Ой вінку, мій вінку ♪
♪ Та я тебе поливала, зелений барвінку. ♪
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
Ой, оце спідниця-фартух.
— Це ж фартух.
— Фартух, називали фартухом.
Оце — припинка, або запаска.
Одні люди кажуть «припинка»,
одні — «запаска».
Сорочка — звичайна сорочка.
Ніяка не блузка,
просто жіноча сорочка.
І оце...
В мене на території
називали «горсет» —
там на польскій території,
а в нас в селі —
«каназейка».
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
Батько наш був відомий музикант,
скрипаль бойківський
Василь
Іванович Ігнахтич.
Ну, і всі околиці його
запрошували на весілля.
Ми були маленькі,
бігали за татом:
як це буде,
як це проходити буде.
— І слухали...
— Ми слухали.
Звичайно, вже по слуху.
Музичний слух ми маємо.
— Ми перейняли.
— Ми перейняли, так.
Перейняли просто
дійсно так,
і тепер по пам'яті
відтворюємо.
Нас вже тепер...
Немає вже.
Є ще пару жіночок старші.
Ми оце — наймолодші носії
фолькльору того.
♪ Ой, барвін, барвіночку, ♪
♪ не стій ти пристіночку, ♪
♪ бо час вінки вити, ♪
♪ молодих благословити. ♪
Це — весільні ладканки
на початок весілля.
Як починалося весілля в нас,
в Бойківському краї,
то заміжні жінки,
обов'язково старшого віку,
починали весілля
такими ладканням.
І ладканки були
не тільки весільні.
Були ладканки були здавнішні:
вони вже не збереглися, на жаль.
Були до худоби,
до жнив —
коли були обжинки — до жнив.
До зачинання сівби.
Також були до різних, ну,
до різних таких ритуальних обрядів,
до різних подій у житті
людини були ладканки.
На данний час
збереглися тільки весільні.
♪  [ грає народна бойківська музика ]
Люди гірські такі — вони такі
більш емоційніші такі, рухливіші.
А вже внизу
там люди повільніші.
Я думаю, що то менталітет все ж таки.
Той такий, закладений десь в генах.
♪ [ грає народна бойківська музика ]
♪ Ой, піде на товаришко межи тії бойки, ♪
♪ сказане все боронити пісеньки легонькі. ♪
♪  [ грає народна бойківська музика ]
[Карпати,
селище Бориня]
Бойко — це є
володар худоби,
так як ковбой
в ранчо.
З покоління в покоління
основними варіантами були: вівчарство,
[Богдан Комарницький,
сировар]
ну і м'ясництво,
скажем так.
Колись я займався
різними варіантами бізнесу, то сьо.
Але потім я зрозумів, що придумувати колесо —
то є пуста робота.
Не буде здоров'я,
і так дальше то всьо.
А коли ось, припустимо,
займаються автетикою, то...
Так воно виходить,
в принципі,
що вам ніби зверху
якісь сили допомагають,
вас направляють, в принципі,
і так далі, і все.
Але я бачив, що в мене життя
змінюється на краще.
Зараз бачу, що чим більше
я купаюся в новому,
тим краще я бачу силу цього.
Сталий розвиток.
Що таке сталий розвиток?
Основні принципи сталого розвитку?
Це є передача інформації
від попереднього покоління до наступного.
О цим Європа
і живе по суті.
А в нас періодами
постійно щось руйнували.
Одні приходили, другі приходили.
В нас немає цього.
Ну ви знаєте,
люди звикли до тих стандартів.
Знаєте, у нас ще той «совок»
не вийшов з людей наших.
Молодь-то
не звертає уваги,
бо молодь не цікавить нічого
в принципі, для більшості.
Свої інтереси мають.
А ті, що совкові, ті речі,
в принципі, ми ...
Наче ми думаємо, що має бути так,
знаєте, як то було за Союзу.
Все було
в певних рамках.
В принципі,
так далі і пішло.
Але я сам зрозумів,
припустимо, що відродження  — то є...
Єдиний правильний шлях —
це відродження.
Чи харчових, чи нехарчових,
то є найбільш правильний варіант.
Це є бездріжовий хліб
з борошна грубого помелу.
Тобто тут в борошні, в принципі,
є те, що має бути.
Якщо ми візьмем
оце борошно, та?
Ту муку, що в нас є
в магазинах зараз,
то там відсутнє те, що має бути,
що людина повинна споживати.
Борошно грубого помелу:
тут є присутнє ядро...
Те, що саме цікаве в зерні є, так?
Це ядро і висівка —
те, що корисно для людини.
Якщо ядро, припустимо,
дає людині енергію,
то висівка — чистить організм.
Тут слабувати почав, в принципі.
Я не міг той
хліб магазинний їсти.
У мене такі відрижки були
та печія, що називається.
Тоді не було так в Україні,
щоб цей дріжджовий хліб можна
було так надибати.
І так далі, то все.
Найперше ми навчився
закваску робити,
бо це, бачте, ваша бабця,
будь-кого з вас,
варила такі дріжджі, бачите?
дріжджі.
Це є природні дріжджі.
Там присутні тільки
борошно грубого помелу і вода,
більше там нічого немає.
Додається вода і воно...
Оце як дріжджі робляться.
Потім ставиться в холодильник.
Перед тим, як випікати, ви витягаєте
знов в тепле місце,
додаєте води.
В принципі, воно вам
набирає дріжджів повну банку.
Те саме в принципі, сидимо біля
адміністрації, десь там говоримо:
чоловік п'ятнадцять-двадцять
сиділо нас.
Я кажу:
«Давайте відроджувати, в принципі,
туризм, ті, інші речі, те, се».
А один присутній там стоїть каже:
«Ти диви, диви. Всі люди вперед,
а він нас назад тягне».
Кажу: «Я не заважаю тобі.
Припустимо...
Використовувати елементи,
де є якісь досягнення.
У тебе ж ніхто машину не забирає.
Якщо б сир сироварня варила,
то зроби якісний сир:
там технологія та сама.
Що було тоді, що зараз.
Ми не мусимо робити так, як раніше,
і втрачати стільки часу.
Але використовувати ті елементи,
які маємо зараз.
Але суть в тому, щоб продукт був
такий, як раніше».
Але цьогоріч виявилося, що я мав рацію.
Поляки цього року були,
з Америки було декілька людей,
з Італії також
представники тут у нас були.
А з України: Харків,
Маріуполь, Мелітополь,
Запоріжжя, Тернопіль та Київ.
Дуже багато людей було
з Дніпропетровська.
Немає такої області в Україні,
хто б не приїздив сюди.
І завжди я жінці наголошую, щоб
ніколи не приховувала
інформації, бо...
Вона вже ніби зрозуміла,
що більше інформації
ми даємо,
то більше ми потім
розвиваємося самі.
Так чомусь у нас виходить,
так чомусь в природі виходить,
ті всі таємниці бізнес, то все є...
На мою думку, то все дурне є.
Комерційна таємниця, то ні.
Розповсюджуй інформацію,
і тим більше рухайся далі вперед.
Я навіть наполягав, на тому,
щоб була мережа сироварень.
Припустимо, що я був би власником.
Створити сироварні:
сирзаводний на п'ять, на десять тон.
Зробити краще три сироварні порізну.
Воно в будь-якому випадку окупиться.
Якість йтиме вам на користь, та й все.
[Карпати,
село Мохнате]
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
[Анатолій Височанський,
музикант]
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
Керую гуртом «Відлуння Карпат»
вокально-інструментальним,
ми маємо апаратуру,
але там в Закарпатті.
Ми граємо весілля.
Грав я в минулу суботу все весілля.
Я маю сина, що грає зі мною весіллі.
Ми граємо обряди:
верховинські, лемківські, бойківскі, гуцульскі
обряди такі старовинні.
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
♪ Ой, так татко мовит. ♪
♪ Най, тебе бог благословить. ♪
♪ Благослови Богойку. ♪
♪ Благослови Богойку ♪
♪ і вінок на головоньку. ♪
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
То є етнос — «бойко»,
а українець — то є національність.
Я думаю, що
бойки — то одна з найбідніших груп.
У нас холодно,
у нас нічого росте,
у нас виноград не дозріває.
А скотарство —
то вищий клас на весь світ.
Дуже легко,
багато землі,
земля пропадає,
ніхто її не обробляє.
Косити сіна можна стільки,
скільки хочете,
худоби мати — і сто голів.
Раніше не дозволяли.
Раніше — то було, коли був Хрущов ще.
У ті часи, в епоху сталінщини,
окрім кіз ніхто нічого не тримав.
Були часи тяжкі,
а тепер виходить інакше.
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
♪ Ай, піду я на весілля ♪
♪ межи тії бойки. ♪
♪ Там музика дрібно грає, ♪
♪ скачуть полегойки, ♪
♪ скачуть полегойки. ♪
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
Якщо взяти наш
бойківський край,
то інакше молоду чильчають.
Потім там є золотий танець.
Йде на нас молода, збирає грошей.
Люди, хто хочуть з молодою танцювати,
то танцюють.
А є інші традиції,
зокрема на Закарпатті.
Там є і Іршавський район,
там дуже багаті райони,
де дають гроші паперові,
добрі гроші.
Але на кілограми:
дуже багато грошей дають.
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
Ми без того жити
не можемо, розумієте?
Бо якщо ми закинемо традиції
та обряди наші старовинні,
нам буде грош ціна
в базарний день.
Бо нема кому ж.
Бачите, яка в нас культура в селах?
У нас ніхто нічого не робить.
У нас у клубах
ніхто нічого не робить.
Треба усім починати з себе.
І шось треба робити,
а не просто пальцем махати.
♪ [ грає бойківська народна музика ]
[автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[оператори
Павло Пашко, Василь Гошовський]
[продюссерка
Оля Шор]
[режисер
Микола Носок]
[звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[монтажерка
Ліза Литвиненко]
[музика
Sasha Boole, Torban]
[субтитрувальник
Олексій Нагаєв]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]